Israel's military has raided the town of
tubas north of Nablus in the occupied
West Bank let's get the latest from HUD
Abdul Hamid who is in rala in the
occupied West Bank so H it's not the
first time tuas has been targeted in
recent days what's going
on well it certainly was a very large
raid that has actually ended now
according to Residents we spoke to um it
is one of those uh area one of those
cities that have been the focus
of Israeli raids for quite a while
because of the presence of Palestinian
resistance there now uh it was about 2
a.m. when a large Convoy of Israeli
armored vehicles made their way into uh
toas followed by bulldozers uh as we
understand it there's been quite a
intense exchange of gunfire there and
then the Israeli Army targeted uh two
houses that have been demolish and we
understand that that was for motor fire
uh we do also uh we were told also that
11 people were detained into bus and
they just pulled out a short while ago
overall there had been six different
raids across the occupied West Bank
including one that is ongoing in the
kandia refugee camp which is a short
drive away from where I'm standing in
ramala it's to the south of the city uh
we do understand that two people have
been detained so far and the Israelis uh
are soldiers are going uh on doing
houseo house uh searches at the moment
uh otherwise there have been also a raid
in nablo that lasted uh about an hour or
so one woman was detained in that one
and then there have been there was also
a raid in Hebron but this one was quite
different in the sense that the the
troops were there to actually confiscate
cars that have illegal licensing from
what we understand is that uh the Army
is searching for a specific card that
was used in a shootout against Israeli
soldiers at a checkpoint south of Hebron
a few days ago and there were also minor
raids in places like budros which is
Northwest of uh ramala we don't have the
total number of detentions that usually
will be issued in the coming hours but
we do know that overall it's been six
raids and at least 14 people
detained thank you for that H abdal
Hamid there for us in rala